le choral un virus attaque lorsque vous
n'avez pas les anticorps nécessaires
pour vous protéger
ce que fait le vaccin c'est de faire
croire à votre organisme qu'il est
attaqué pour le forcer à se défendre en
créant cette immunité et le grand
avantage du vaccin
c'est que vous n'avez pas besoin d'être
infectés par le virus pour construire
cette protection
dans ses laboratoires luc gagnon docteur
en microbiologie et immunologie analyse
et mesure l'efficacité des études
vaccinale et des vaccins il y en a
plusieurs qui sont déjà prêts pour se
protéger contre ce fameux virus il
existe deux sortes de vaccins les
premiers ce sont les classiques dans les
vaccins classiques on retrouve
effectivement les virus inactivé ou
atténuée on retrouve également ce qu'on
appelle les vaccins sous unitaire qui
correspond seulement une petite portion
du virus et on retrouve les vaccins sont
des vaccins composé de particules
semblables des virus qui ne contiennent
pas de code génétique et ne sont donc
pas effectué l'autre sortes de vaccins
ce sont ceux qu'on appelle les modernes
comme modern art et phaser dont la
distribution va commencer la semaine
prochaine ici au canada
oui effectivement ce genre de vaccins
c'est des vaccins révolutionnaire qui ne
sont composés que du code génétique du
corps vide soit la rn message
[Musique]
les canadiens vont recevoir un de ces
quatre vaccins
mais que se passe-t-il lorsqu'on se fait
injecter ce vaccin dans l'organisme
suite à l'administration du vaccin chez
l'individu le vaccin vont se distribuer
dans l'entièreté du cac les globules
blancs qui font partie du système
immunitaire vont venir en robe et les
particules vaccinales qui composent le
vaccin est déclenchée deux réponses
immunitaires une réponse humorale ou une
réponse est là donc le premier type de
réponse lorsqu'on est vaccinée c'est la
réponse tumorale
en effet la réponse humorale correspond
à la production les anticorps qui sont
les soldats produits afin de protéger
l'organisme contre les infections
virales
alors qu'est ce qui se passe lorsque je
suis vacciné mais j'entre en contact
malgré tout avec le fameux virus les
anticorps qui ont été produits lors de
la vaccination vont entourer le virus et
le neutraliser
donc la réponse humorale avec les
soldats mais aussi la réponse cellulaire
et là la réponse cellulaire on met
vraiment le paquet contre le virus ouais
effectivement la réponse cellulaire fait
intervenir les globules blancs pour
laquelle ils vont neutraliser carrément
le virus via la destruction des cellules
qui sont infectés par ce virus même
alors le virus et de tra lisez est
anéantie et disparaît est ce que ça veut
dire que là je suis protégé
les études ont démontré que les
individus étaient protégés avec la
vaccination
par contre la question demeure pour la
protection a longtemps en attendant la
confirmation que le vaccin bloc ou
empêche la diffusion du virus et qu'une
majorité de personnes soient vaccinés
pour arriver à l'immunité collective une
autorité de santé publique recommande
toujours le port du masque et la
distanciation sociale
[Musique]